hall-of-famer inside the NBA analyst
Charles Barkley joining us Chuck how's
your summer going off and fish you know
what's going good
what are you better at fishing or
playing golf well you get to drink and
smoking you I drink I drink more when I
play golf and it's full-on plan with the
guys so listen the golf is always my
thing man long as I smoke two or three
stogies and drink a little bit I'm happy
I give you credit though you love the
game so much and I know that your golf
numbers don't reflect your love for the
game or the time you put into it but
what what is it about that makes you
keep coming back it get to get away from
people you know it did you know when you
go to the supermarket people want to
talk to you go to the dry cleaner people
want to talk to you you know fishing and
golfing you just with your guys there's
nobody around there's no autographs
there's no pictures that that's what's
great about golf and fishing do you get
embarrassed at all with going no no no
I'm out there just to get peace and
quiet man do I wish I could be greeted
go often yes but the main thing the
reason I started playing golf because
you know I've been in in limelight since
I was 18 years old it wears down man
think about it
I've been in the limelight since I was
18 now I'm 55 you just need a break man
I mean just you know you it part of it
is autograph part of it as pictures I
think you should always sign autographs
I think she's always take pictures but
man you got to admit sometimes you just
want to be left alone
are you following what's going on in the
NBA in the offseason vaguely I'll check
in on the owner the mothership
at the end of the day and see what's
happening when I said mother I mean
myself but I'll check in but I don't sit
where I'm not one of these to sit around
I've worked on it every day because
whatever happened during the summer
don't mean anything you know
you got a month with preseason start so
you can figure it out they're
handicapped the trade then with demar
derozan Kawhi Leonard you make sense of
it that's a great trade for both teams I
think it's great for the Spurs the
DeMars a hell of a player that Kate
listen that kid Jacob portal I think as
I pronounced a media player I mean so
there's a great trade apart by the Spurs
you know I think if you take your head
off to Messiah Pitzer Otto's arguably
one or two or three pairs you know
massive leaks taking a swing for it B so
they're better
both teams are probably better than they
were yesterday and it's gonna be great
for dispersed but they going out those
guys put it back five years of or at
least three years with Jabbar
but listen it's up to the Raptors and
Heath DeMarco I was gonna realize
Toronto is one of the two or three best
cities in the world it's my favorite
city
I don't know if he want to stay there
but it's one of my favorite city it's
right up there with Chicago in my
opinion as the best fit is around and
I'm thinking convinced him to stay you
know they're right there with the
Celtics and the citrus that's the three
best teams in the Eastern Conference how
do you assess what LeBron is gonna have
to work with this upcoming season how
high should the expectations be number
five seed maybe six in the West not sure
that they want I don't think they're
better than Oklahoma City I don't think
they're better than the Denver Nuggets
clearly the Rockets to me are the
surprised people I think they have
regrets I'm a big Trevor Ariza fan
I love Trevor Ariza but Minnesota's
better than the Lakers so I don't like
critical on is I see them as a four or
five sixty yeah it's it's curious that
they brought in Rondo and JaVale McGee
and Lance Stephenson kind of oneand
owners here it feels like just to get to
the you know 2019
you see it that what happened I think
they kind of just bought the plane guys
in their sales some tickets other I mean
give us give us some attention I mean
I'm a Browns gonna do his thing
he's that great but those other teams
out west that the West's unbelievable
Phoenix got better Sacramento is going
to be better I mean it's gonna be very
difficult
LeBron you know like he got 20 easy wins
the last 30 years he won't get those
easy 20 wins at a Western Conference I
mean so you know when they go to Denver
man Denver's really get better
I think Denver's better than the Lakers
you know I mean silver brother in his
age he's great it's gonna be interesting
how hard liquors can get yeah I'm
curious that to that I think the
over/under is 50 wins for the Lakers
this year what do you think of that
number I think they're right in that
neighborhood what's going to be
interested you know they've brought in
all those old guys but the key to their
futures all of those young guys yes I
mean because did this year's about Paul
Ingram Kuzma guys like that and are they
gonna sacrifice those guys getting
better to play those old views they
brought in to win another five years
talking to Charles Barkley Hall of Famer
inside the NBA analyst joining us Dan
Patrick show I don't know if you follow
this as well at the all-star break where
the Commissioner of Major League
Baseball talked about Mike Trout and hey
Mike you got to help us market you and
you you know you have sort of a
responsibility as the best player in the
game we have this in the NBA
soccer players worldwide with Messi and
Ronaldo and Neymar but when it comes to
baseball how much should this be on Mike
Trout to be part of the marketing of
Mike Trout for the benefit of Major
League Baseball
you know I bet Mike Trout there was an
honor and a privilege that got justice
still he's you know you know he's the
best player in the game I don't know
what more he can do I mean other than
winning MVP every year and dominate
every night I don't know that could he
be in more commercials probably but the
main for me got their team not very good
so I don't think you can have a guy
who's not all of who's not only a good
team because if he was winning it'd be
totally different he'd be on TV every
week and people will talk about it more
but until they get a better team I think
that's just really isn't it's just
hogwash
but you back you but we didn't talk
about marketing back when you played or
you know magic marketing or Larry or
Michael or Isiah
you're kind of marketed because you were
very good and teams played I mean you
got so much attention when you went to
the finals against the Bulls
I don't know how much attention you got
prior to that nationally but it felt
like people were introduced to you back
when you you know in the early 90s when
you faced off against Jordan in the
Bulls team wasn't pre I mean it's just
about how it your team is I mean I was a
much better player in Philly and I was
and feelings but until we got to the
finals I didn't get the proper the
credit I deserve but I was a much better
player and as fairly as I was in Phoenix
and I was blessed to get Dan Majerle and
Kevin Johnson and win everything but
it's really it's actually a great
example as great as I was in Philly we
were not winning and I didn't get my
duel until I got to Phoenix and I got
help for Marquess Ceballos of those guys
with Kevin if they had borrowed here's
another thing that we were talking about
that everybody's trying to kind of
emulate what the building State Warriors
do and I feel like that's listen you
know listen people think I don't
I hate analytics and now I'm gonna do it
because it's true I hate analytics
listen you can't win a game by shoot
threes unless you got a stamp clay and
carry their rap those guys could be
analytical that's the only reason it
worked
now they've totally taken a big guy off
the game which if I play the distant
warriors I'd beat them up physically
inside but they don't want to play I
make them play big guy yeah but now you
got these other guys around a leak
irrebuttably let's just shoot threes
less you trees less you treat that I'm
like listen unless you have clay clay
Stefan Kevin is not going to work and
that's the way is working now if you got
those guys they these guys probably
almost a prize should have won four
championships in a row of three mine I
doubt they're filing people but this is
you can only shoot threes if you got
those three guys if you're the greatest
offensive players ever
and even you go back and look they don't
have to play great but they could one of
those guys can make enough threes on a
given night and make them pretty much
unbeatable but I don't understand why
these other teams are trying to immolate
good guys because they don't have those
three guys yeah that's my point is I
think somebody's gonna be do a
counter-attack and I want to I want to
get Golden State's attention where you
have to play defense on my guys on our
style instead of you know Golden State
makes you play their game you get sucked
into it you know LeBron tried to build a
Golden State in the east and you just
you didn't have the talent to be able to
go head-to-head with them but I I get
the feeling that somebody's gonna go all
right we're gonna play good perimeter
defense and we want you to guard our
bigs down down below and let's take our
chances here I don't understand why
you're trying to use the analogy of a
boxing match you know I'm not gonna try
to out there and try to I'd box Floyd
Mayweather because he's the best
defensive fighter but I'm just gonna hey
listen let's be the filler and I'm gonna
punch you in your head and I don't
understand why I like this they got a
small little team yeah they're terrific
now but I'm gonna get the ball get me a
big guy on the post I want
try to get a dream on or Cabot Durant in
foul trouble but I'm gonna tell you I'm
not gonna place fall I don't think you
can beat them playing small I'm having
this conversation with Kevin McHale he's
like I don't understand why everybody
wants to play small against the Golden
State Warriors you're not going to beat
them like that but now you've got all
these analytical idiots around the whole
running pa-dow
and they're trying to act like having a
good big guy is not a bad thing like he
can get your layups and get you dance
you can get the other team in foul
trouble but all of a sudden one team
does something so they got to the
greatest offensive players ever and
they're like everybody's like let's try
that well you can try but you're not
gonna shoot bad those guys so they're
wasting their time I thought the Lakers
we're gonna go after DeMarcus Cousins
like I thought that that you know they
you could take a chance on him like
Golden State's doing and if you could I
don't know it just felt like that if
you're gonna play something different
than golden state then DeMarcus Cousins
is available at a good price and you can
you know you're sort of having a test
you know a trial run here this next
season with LeBron I don't know why they
didn't reach out and try to get DeMarcus
Cousins a lot of a player and if you
could get him for five million thousand
one year it should have been 15 teams
who were right there who like maybe not
went championship level but like maybe
we can win the East
maybe we should surprise them please in
the West because the only team being the
West we got to worry about like I'm not
down on the Rockets a little bit several
reasons one of my favorite players
they're gonna miss him the Rockets have
done it this time
so I think they take a step back but if
I'm one of those other three or four
teams in the West I get the farthest
culture or find a of dollars.you such a
total number when he's gonna be
motivated because number one he's bad
and secondly you know he's got to play
well to get another big contract yeah so
I think a lot of
please Luis not going after the Bacchus
yeah I'm right there with you got
anything exciting on the agenda for the
rest of the summer I think that golf and
fishing I will try to get the answer
damn I'm right there with you
yeah I'm right there with you I I can do
nothing in been be content how big do
you think like you're known in Amsterdam
can you walk down the streets there in
Amsterdam and nobody bothers you well
safe travels and good to talk to you
again Charles Thank You Charles
yeah good hi buddy
Charles Barkley Hall of Famer inside the
NBA analyst as well going to Amsterdam
what could go wrong for Charles going to
Amsterdam there for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
ass
[Music]